The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We're
going to continue
our discussion of correlation
functions, and in particular,
g2 of 0.
If you think I'm focusing a
lot on one quantity, g2 of 0,
that's correct.
But I have to tell
you, I have been
involved in so many
discussions with people
who looked at g2 of 0 with
both Einstein condensates
when Bose-Einstein condensates
in [INAUDIBLE] were discovered
here at MIT by [INAUDIBLE]
and collaborators.
There was some mystery about, in
essence, the g2 of 0 function.
So a lot of physics
actually goes into it.
And I've learned a lot
from my own research
and through discussions.
And in this unit, I
want to summarize it.
So the confusion sometimes
comes because people
use classical pictures,
quantum pictures,
and they may not
see the relation.
So let's continue
the discussion.
I want to go through
four different views
of the same physics
that you will
recognize that
they're interrelated.
The first one, just
to repeat that,
is if you have light which
is Gaussian intensity
fluctuations, light
from random sources.
I think if you would look
at the twinkle of starlight,
if you look at the
light from a light bulb,
because of the
central limit theorem,
you will find that the intensity
that the electric field
has a Gaussian distribution,
and the intensity
in exponential distribution.
And if you then ask, what is
g2 of 0, you'll find it's 2.
Because for an
exponential distribution,
the average of the
intensity squared
is two times the intensity,
the average of the-- what
did I say.
This average of the
squared intensity
is two times the average
of the intensity squared.
Before I forget it, one
student asked me after class,
I'm discussing g2 of 0,
but what about g2 of tau?
Well, my understanding is
that almost all of the physics
is in g2 of 0.
And there is a simple number,
1 or 2, in those special cases.
What happens is, if you have
completely independent sources,
if you completely
independent statistics,
then the probability of
finding a second particle,
a second photon, is
independent of the first.
So it means g2 of
tau would be unity.
This is the case for an
uncoordinated system.
But if you have g2 of 0 which is
higher, this means correlation.
This means some
form of coherence.
And usually, the
correlated value simply
decays to the uncorrelated value
with a characteristic coherence
time.
And this characteristic
coherence time
can be inhomogeneous, technical.
It can be limited by the Fourier
transform of a light pulse,
the monochromaticity,
the bend which
delta omega is 1 over tau.
So it has all of
the usual suspects
for what limits
the coherence time.
So therefore in
general, we're not
learning something fundamental
in looking at g2 of tau.
We're just learning the usual
spiel about correlation times
and coherence times.
The second angle I gave you
with the brief interference
is something which
is deeply insightful.
It shows you the following.
If you have a plane wave,
the intensity is constant.
If you have two plane
waves which interfere,
you create density fluctuations,
because the interference
pattern can be constructive
and can be destructive.
So therefore, if the
intensity fluctuates,
then i square average is
no longer i average square.
And what happens is because
of the nature of interference,
because the average of
cosine square kx is-- well,
there are factors of 1/2
and 2 which just come out
of cosine and sine
square function.
You get exactly g2 of 2.
But that should already
tell you something,
which will be important for both
quantum particles, and light,
and the classic limit.
The moment if you have light or
particles in one single mode,
you can't have any
form of interference.
Only two modes can interfere.
And you will always
get a g2 function of 1.
But we'll come to
that in a second.
Any questions at that point?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I thought that when
we talked about the g2 function
several weeks ago, you said
that if we had a single mode
thermal light, it would
have the g2 function of 2.
And that's therefore,
all we were
using for lasers when we
used them in experiments
is the fact that it's single
mode, not the coherence
in the g2 function.
PROFESSOR: You have a good--
that's a good point, Cory.
Let's just try to
connect the two pictures.
Slowly, slowly.
What did we discuss?
This question is great for
me to repeat something.
When we looked at
black body radiation,
I wrote down the
partition function.
And I said I'm only
considering a single mode.
And then, we have of course
in thermal equilibrium
a Boltzmann type, or
Bose-Einstein type,
distribution of finding
certain numbers,
number of photons
populating the single mode.
And that resulted in
a g2 function of 2.
AUDIENCE: It's not really
single mode though, right?
Because you're summing
over many frequencies.
PROFESSOR: No, it
was single frequency.
I have to think about it.
That's a really good question.
Right now, I would quickly
say, in thermal equilibrium--
I'll give you partial answer,
and when I think about it,
I'll give you full
answer on Friday
at the beginning
of the next class--
I think would be
calculated where
the thermal fluctuations
in the intensity.
And the intensity fluctuations,
and those intensity
fluctuations.
Those intensity fluctuations
result in a g2 function of 2.
That's correct.
Maybe what I want
you to say here
is, if you have two modes
which have all maybe
single occupation or
constant occupation,
and they interfere, then they
create a spatial interference
pattern if the phase between
the two modes is random,
which gives rise to
additional fluctuation.
So most likely, the two
fluctuations are independent.
One is the fluctuations
because of the interference
of two modes.
But when I say the single
mode has a g2 function of 1,
I meant actually a single
mode with constant amplitude.
I'll double check and give you a
more complete answer on Friday.
Other questions?
OK.
The third view is classical
versus quantum statistics.
And I think this really
shows that we need at least
some quantumness to
find correlations.
Let's assume we
have n particles.
And we have N possible states.
And if it's a
classical system, let's
assume we want to find one
particle in a certain state.
We have a big box and want
to-- we have a big box,
have a small
sub-volume, and say what
is the probability of
finding one particle here?
So this probability
to find one particle
is P1 is small n over big
N. The probability to find
two particles.
If you have non-interacting
classical particles,
well, it's simply P1 squared.
Independent classical
particles, they
don't care what they are doing.
You grab into a
sub-volume, which
is maybe phase space cell.
And therefore,
your quantum state,
you have probability
P of finding one.
But since each particle
moves around independently,
the probability to find two
particles is just P squared.
It's a little bit like if
you toss two coins, one
with your left and
one with your right,
and you ask what
is the probability
to find a head or
tail, and you simply
multiply the probabilities.
But now, following reasonings
which Bose and Einstein
introduced, you want to use
counting statistics, which
takes into account the
indistinguishability
of particles.
So if we go from the
classical distribution
to the distribution of
indistinguishable particles,
then the classical probability
P 1 is reduced by n factorial,
because we are not--
let me put it this way.
The number-- I don't
want to go through
a mathematical argument.
If you grab one particle,
it can be the probability
to find one particle
is represented
by a microconfiguration
classically.
And each configuration
when you permute particles
counts as independent.
But if you have quantum
indistinguishability,
you're not counting
permutations as
an independent configuration.
And therefore, you have a
reduction by n factorial.
If you look at the probability
of finding two particles,
the reduction is-- this is
just the counting statistics
n factorial by 2.
So therefore, you will find
that classically, that quantum
mechanically for
bosons, is two times.
The probability to find two
bosons in one quantum state
is two times the probability
squared to find one boson.
So this is just
counting statistics.
This can be applied
to conditions
in a Bose-Einstein
in a Bose gas.
When you have inelastic
collisions, spin relaxation,
dipolar collisions,
two body collisions,
two-body collisions
have a rate gamma 2,
which is proportional to
the probability of finding
two particles at the same
time at the same location.
And that brings in
the g2 function.
Whereas three-body
collisions, gamma 3,
reflects the third
order correlation
function g3, which is
defined in an analogous way.
So if you now compare
at the same density
the two-body rate coefficient,
like the same density
means we are looking at the
rate of two-body collisions.
And we compare between
two-body collision
in a thermal cloud, which
is a g2 factor of two,
a thermal cloud of bosons.
Whereas a Bose-Einstein
condensate
is a constant occupation
of particles in one mode
and has therefore a g2 factor
of 1, exactly as [INAUDIBLE]
of the Bose-Einstein
condensate is
for particles for meta waves,
but the laser is for light.
Whereas, if you look at
three-body collisions,
those who do experiments with
Bose-Einstein condensates
will know that
usually the lifetime
of Bose-Einstein
condensates is limited
by three-body collisions.
Well, I didn't derive
it, but actually
yes, we have the Gaussian
statistics for randomness.
For Gaussian statistics, the
n-body collision function
has a factor of n factorial.
So therefore,
three-body collisions
scale with 3 factorial, and
two-body collisions with 2
factorial.
So in other words, you
have a thermal cloud,
you have a Bose-Einstein
condensate at the same density.
But what matters for
two-body collision
is not the average density.
It is the average of n square.
And the fluctuations
in the thermal cloud
because of the g2 function
are two times enhanced
compared to
Bose-Einstein condensate.
And therefore, you find
that at the same density,
you have more loss.
You have a higher rate of two
and three-body collisions.
Some of this was not--
became better understood
soon after Bose-Einstein
condensates were realized.
The Boulder group studied
three-body collisions.
And for two-body
collisions, myself
in the post-doc
clarified the situation
that even the mean field energy,
which everybody had measured
before, requires two particles
to interact with short range
interaction is therefore
proportional to g2.
And therefore, when people
had determined the mean field
energy of a condensate
without really knowing
they had already
determined the g2 function
of Bose-Einstein condensates.
OK, so this is pretty much
the counting statistic
which you do in
undergraduate class
when you derive the three
different statistics--
Boltzmann statistics,
Bose-Einstein statistics, Fermi
statistics.
And it gives you the result
of that is also for bosons,
you have the factor of 2.
For fermions, of
course, you get 0.
The average between bosons
2 and fermions 0 is 1.
And this is the
classical statistics.
Any questions?
Then let me finish
this discussion
with a quantum
mechanical description.
If you describe the
detection or collision of two
particles in two modes.
So you have mode.
A mode operator, annihilation
operator a1 you and a2.
But if you are
asking what happens
if I measure two particles,
you annihilate two particles
with an operator a1 and a2.
But then, because of
the indistinguishability
of particles, you
have to consider
an exchange term, which is a2a1.
So whenever you
detect two particles
in two different
modes, your signal
is proportional to something
related to a1a2 plus a2a1.
This extra exchange term
gives you an extra factor of 2
for bosons, which is
exactly what appears
in the g2 function.
And, of course, if you have
an exchange term for fermions,
you get 0.
And this, of course,
leads to the antibunching,
or the g2 value
of 0 for fermions.
However, and this is obvious,
if you have a single mode,
then the only operator to detect
two particles is a1 times a1.
And this has no exchange term.
And this is the
situation of the laser
and the Bose-Einstein
condensate.
And that means they
have a g2 function of 1.
So Cory, this is
another argument
why single mode occupation
has a g2 function of 1.
But I have to reconcile
it with your question.
Right now, I think
there may be difference
between a canonical ensemble
and grand canonical ensemble.
In a canonical ensemble,
we have [INAUDIBLE]
the total particle
number is fixed.
But in a grand
canonical it fluctuates.
And maybe this leads to
additional fluctuations
for the case of a single
mode chaotic light.
But I will have to think
about it, your question.
But here is the
same argument why
if you occupy only a
single mode-- if you look,
for instance, at a
Bose-Einstein condensate,
you do not have the
second exchange term.
And the missing
exchange term just
propagates through the
equations and gives you
the g2 factor, the
g2 function of 1.
OK so let me sort of wrap it up.
I've given you different
angles at the g2 function.
Some are simply classical
intensity distribution.
Some is simply interference.
Another aspect is Poissonian
counting statistics.
My understanding and
my interpretation
is they look as different
as they can possibly look,
but they reflect
the same physics.
Because interference of to
light only happens because light
consists of photons.
And photons are bosons.
So the classical
interference and
the quantum mechanical
counting of bosons
lead not for random reasons,
but lead for profound reasons
to the same result.
And chaotic light, which
seems to be determined
by just random
fluctuation, well,
the random fluctuations
if you have single mode
light, a thermal distribution
of single mode photons,
comes from random phases.
And these random phases
lead to random interference.
And so we are back
to interference.
Finally, let me give you my
view on the measurements of g2.
When you look through
the literature,
you find the famous Henry
[INAUDIBLE] experiment.
In one of your
homework assignments,
you looked at a
seminal experiment
where people dropped atoms
out of cold atom clouds
and measured the g2
function for cold atoms.
Sometimes it's confusing
when you directly
compare the two experiments.
But let me try to give
you a common description,
or the common denominator,
between all these experiments.
You can say that all experiments
to measure the two particle
correlation function
is about comparing
the probability of finding two
particles with a probability
of finding one particle.
And well, you restrict your
measurement, your detection
of particles, to
either one quantum
state, one mode of the
electromagnetic field, one
coherence length, or
coherence volume, of light.
Or if you use the semi-classical
argument for the description
of particles, you take
one phase space cell.
This is one phase space cell,
one mode, one coherence volume,
one quantum state, is sort
of the different definitions
of what a quantum state
is, or what a wave packet
is with Heisenberg
limited uncertainty.
You cannot define a particle
in phase space to within better
than the phase space
volume of a quantum state,
which is h square.
Or is it h bar?
I don't think there
is a bar-- h square.
And so this is how you
can relate wave packets
to quantum states to
phase space volume.
It's pretty much mathematically
I could say in different basis
sets, in different basis
sets, it is one quantum state.
But you can use wave packets.
You can use time
dependent description.
But what I said here--
one quantum state,
one mode, one
coherence volume-- this
is as well as you can
define a particle or photon
to be by fundamental reasons
by Heisenberg's uncertainty
relation.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean
by one coherence volume?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: What do we mean
by one coherence volume?
PROFESSOR: Well, if you have
a laser beam which propagates,
and it is TEM00, you would say
the transverse coherence volume
is the size of the
laser beam but then
the longitudinal
coherence volume
is given by the
coherence length.
Just envision you have
a laser beam here.
And the coherence volume where
all of the photons are coherent
is the area of the laser beam
times the coherence length.
And whenever you find a
photon in this kind of volume,
then it is in a
Heisenberg Uncertainty
limited or
Fourier-limited state.
It is in, if it's a wave
packet and pulse laser,
it's in a time
dependent quantum state.
But it is as coherent.
It is fully coherent.
So you have to figure
out for your system what
is this minimum-- what is the
coherence volume, what defines
the fundamental phase
space cell of your system?
And now you do the following.
You are asking, what
is the probability
to find two particles?
And what is the probability
to find one particle?
So if p is the probability
to find one particle,
then you have three options.
p square, 2 p square or
0 to find two particles.
One is the classical case
of distinguishable particle.
This is the case of bosons,
bosonic atoms or photons.
Collins Therefore includes the
Hanbury Brown-Twiss experiment.
And 0 is fermions.
And the question is now
different experiments,
how do you define,
with spatial resolution
or temporal resolution,
the coherence volume?
And that can involve
transverse coordination,
temporal resolution,
and whatever
you can use to define
the phase space
cell or the coherence links,
the coherence volume of a laser
beam.
Let me give you one example,
which I think illustrates it.
And this is the example
of an atom cloud.
If you have an atom
cloud, all the particles
which are in a volume of a
thermal de Broglie wavelengths
are coherent.
The momentum uncertainty of
particles in a thermal cloud
is 1 over the thermal--
is the thermal momentum.
And according to Heisenberg,
the position uncertainty
related with this
momentum spread
is just the thermal de
Broglie wavelengths.
So you can say that all the
atoms in a cubic de Broglie
wavelengths are coherent.
All the atoms are in one
semi-classical quantum state.
So therefore, this is sort
of atoms in one single mode.
So the Hanbury Brown-Twiss
experiment with atoms,
or the measurement
of the g2 function,
could be defined as follows.
You have an atom cloud.
And if you had an
electron microscope
or some high resolution device,
you grab into your cloud
and ask, what is the
probability for one particle.
What is the probability
for two particles?
And you will find that
p2 is 2 times p1 squared.
If your volume is too big,
you lose the factor of 2,
because you average over
uncorrelated volumes.
Now, in your homework, you
were looking at the question,
how can I really
grab into a cloud
and just pick out atoms
out of one phase space
cell of effective size,
lambda de Broglie cubed?
And the way how it was done
is that you take an atom cloud
and you drop it and expand it.
When the cloud expands, there
is a mapping from momentum space
into position space.
Then you use some
form of pinhole,
which provides
transverse coordination.
You use a detection laser, which
gives you temporal resolution.
And well, this was
part of your homework,
but I just wanted to give
you the bird's view on it.
By controlling the
transverse correlation
and the temporal resolution
of the detection,
you create a situation that
what you count only atoms which
originated from one phase
space cell in your cloud.
So in other words,
let's say experiment
where without
electron microscope,
without submicron
spatial resolution,
you can literally
grab into a cloud,
capture a volume of the
thermal de Broglie wavelengths,
open your hand,
and figure out how
is the probability for
two particles related
to the probability of
finding one particle.
Any questions?
All right.
OK, good.
So it's time for new chapter.
So in this chapter,
we want to look
at interactions
between light and atoms
using Feynman diagrams.
And I know this part of the
course is a little bit formal.
We are using exact solutions
for the time evolution
operator in quantum physics.
But I'm not doing it to teach
you sophisticated formalism.
Well, it's interesting
to learn it anyway.
But it is this picture
of really writing down
the exact solution of the
time evolution operator, which
helped me to understand much
better what virtual states are,
what certain
virtual photons are.
So there are things we
talk about it all the time.
And the question is, how do
you define a virtual state?
What is the virtual
emission of a photon?
And the only way how I can
really explain it to you
is by showing you the
equation and say look,
the virtual photon is just
a term in this equation.
So that's the goal
of this chapter.
I don't want to overemphasize
the mathematical rigor,
but I want to
really show you what
it means to have
virtual photons and what
exactly virtual states are.
So let me first motivate that by
reminding you of two diagrams.
In physics, we always
like to draw something--
a few lines, a few doodles.
And when we have a
two level system,
we have the two processes which
are emission and absorption.
Well, so this is easy as long
as the light is in resonance.
But if the light is
not in resonance,
we may ask what
about this process?
And since somehow the weekly
line of the photon ends here,
I may even put in a
dashed line and say,
this is a virtual state.
What does it mean?
Or we can even ask,
is it possible--
I'm just playing with straight
lines which are quantum state
and wiggly lines--
is it possible
that this process happens.
That would actually mean that
an atom in the ground state,
just out of the
blue, emits a photon.
Can that happen?
And I can again
draw a dashed line
and say, here's a virtual state.
Or, we can say we start
in the excited state.
The atom is in
the excited state.
But can the atom-- its
a two level system,
so we don't include higher
states-- but can a two level
atom in the excited state
absorb another photon?
So let me just change the
color of these photons
to red, because I want to--
and this would remain black.
All right.
Good.
So question is, are
those processes possible?
Yes or no?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes, they are.
And they have experimental,
observable consequences.
However, they look
funny because something
seems to be strange with
energy conservation.
And what we will see
is that in the end,
at the end of the
day, that means
if you let the system evolve for
a long time, after a long time,
energy has to be conserved.
And therefore, we will
always need a second photon
to conserve energy.
So those weirder
processes, where
photons are emitted
by ground states out
of the blue or excited
states absorb other photons
without-- also, there is
no higher lying state.
That looks a little bit strange.
So what you will
see is-- and I want
to show you that
mathematically--
if an atom emits a photon
out of the ground state,
you would say, where does
the energy come from.
But quantum mechanic allows us
to violate energy conservation
by an amount delta e for a time
which is h bar over delta e.
So for short movement,
energy can be violated.
But then, you need
the second photon
to reconcile energy
conservation.
You can violate energy
only for short times.
And if you would say,
what does it really
mean to violate energy
conservation for short times?
Well, I want to show
you the equation,
which exactly explains
what it means.
Next question, just to see.
If you have an excited
state, and you just
say it's possible to
absorb another atom,
you are in the excited state,
and you absorb another photon.
And at least you said,
yes this is possible.
My question is, when you
are in the excited state
and absorb a photon, in which
quantum state is the atom
after absorbing a photon?
AUDIENCE: Ground state.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: In the ground state.
Yes.
There is no other state.
And the operator--
and I want to show you
that-- when photons
are exchanged,
always transforms the
ground to the excited state,
because a dipole
operator connects
the ground to the excited state.
So therefore-- but we'll see
that all in the time evolution
operator in the formal solution
that this dash line is actually
the ground state.
And while it's not obvious,
what is this dash line?
AUDIENCE: The excited state.
PROFESSOR: It is
the excited state.
The atom in the ground
state emits a photon.
Therefore, the atomic
system has now lower energy,
because a photon
has been emitted.
But the character of this
state is now the excited state.
So we will later see that this
means that in a perturbation
analysis, we are
violating energy.
We are violating energy,
because the real excited
state is omega photon plus
omega atom, the resonant energy
for the atom.
The real excited state is omega
photon plus omega atom higher.
So you will actually find that
in a perturbation analysis,
this term has an energy
denominator, which
is of resonant by
exactly this separation.
And this term, because the
real count state is here,
the virtual state here which
is the count state is here,
has actually the same energy
denominator as that state.
And for this state,
of course, this
is something you've seen of
resonant light scattering.
The energy
[? denominator ?] is there.
So, OK.
So I'll explain to you that
we involve virtual states.
So when we have
virtual states, we
want to clarify what
is their energy.
But we discussed that
already in the discussion.
And what is the wave function,
ground or excited state.
Yes.
So just to repeat it, when
we draw those diagrams,
those diagrams show
the energy of the atom,
but taking into account
the energy of the photon.
In other words, if you
have a ground state,
and we absorb a photon,
the photon has disappeared,
and the energy of
the atom is now
the ground state and
the photon energy.
And this is a dashed line.
Similarly, when an atom emits
a photon in the ground state,
the photon is emitted.
Therefore, the atomic energy
is lower than the ground state
by the photon energy.
And we draw the
dashed line here.
This is what we mean
when we say that is
the energy of the virtual state.
And this is what we
draw in those diagrams.
By the way, yesterday
we had the CUA seminar.
And the speaker was actually
talking about trapping atoms
with quantum fluctuations.
And he conceded
explicitly Casimir forces,
forces of the vacuum.
And diagrammatically,
forces of the vacuum
come, because the ground state
atom emits a virtual photon
and reabsorbs.
This is actually, I
will mention it later,
the same diagram
is actually also
the diagram which leads
to the Lamb shift.
These are all sort of when you
have atoms in the lowest state,
and they interact with
the electromagnetic field.
Well, if they interact
with the vacuum,
they cannot absorb photon.
All we can do is emit a photon,
and this leads to this diagram.
But just to tell you that
you have to be careful,
yesterday's speakers
actually used this process.
But he drew this diagram.
He drew it in the
opposite way, which
I think confused some
people in the audience.
The correct way is
to draw it like this.
The virtual state for
vacuum fluctuations
for the Lamb shift
for the Casimir force
is below the current state.
OK, so we have-- let me just
redraw those three diagrams.
I want to now introduce
the time evolution.
So I want to use those.
Seems I'm running out of space.
So we want to
introduce the time axis
for-- so we had this diagram.
We had this diagram.
And we had-- this
is a virtual state.
OK.
So those three
diagrams correspond
to the following situation.
If time evolves from
the bottom to the top,
we can now draw
the first process
when atom in the
ground state first
absorbs and then emits a photon.
And let's label the second
photon in the purple color.
So an atom starts out
in the ground state.
Then it reaches
the time where it
interacts the
electromagnetic field.
There is a photon
which propagates
from earlier times to this
time, t equals t prime.
At the time t prime,
the photon disappears.
And the atom, which was
in the ground state,
goes to the excited state.
It may propagate in the
excited state for a while.
And then it emits the photon and
is back into the ground state.
So this is the temporal
diagram for this process.
For the next situation,
we also start
with an atom in
the ground state.
But now we have the
situation that a photon
is emitted by the ground state.
As a result, the atom
switches to the excited state.
Strong violation of energy,
but possible for short times.
Then there is a real photon,
which is now absorbed,
absorbed by an atom
in the excited state.
And that takes us back
down to the ground state.
And finally, in
the third scenario,
we have an atom in
the excited state.
There is a real photon
which is absorbed
that switches the atom
into the ground state.
And then the atom in the
ground state emits a photon.
And as a result, it is
back in the excited state.
So let me just make a note
that when a ground state
atom absorbs a photon, this
is the co-rotating term
in the quantum description,
which a lot of you have seen.
The opposite process of
emitting a virtual photon-- I
shouldn't say virtual photon.
It's a photon.
What makes it virtual
we will see later
when we have the more accurate
mathematical formulation.
So this is a
counter-rotating term.
And we have used the rule
that every photon, which
with a real or virtual-- every
photon which is interchanged
with the atom
absorbs or emitted--
changes the atomic state
from ground to excited.
So an atom goes from the
ground to the excited state
either by photon absorption
or by photon emission.
Both is possible.
So whenever photon
appears or disappears,
it changes-- let's say we
start in the ground state.
We go to the excited state.
And this is possible
by photon absorption--
this is a co-rotating
term-- or emission.
What I've just said
reflects that when
we derived the
dipole approximation,
that the essential term of the
dipole operator is of diagonal.
The dipole operator
is an operator
between calm and excited state.
Therefore, it has those
two matrix elements.
Whereas electric field
operator is the equation
and annihilation
operator a and a dagger.
Or which is very elegant
if I use for the two level
system a spin one
half description.
And I use sigma plus
and sigma minus,
raising and lowering operator.
Sigma plus takes the ground
state to the excited state.
Sigma minus takes the exciting
state to the ground state.
Then in the fundamental
atom light interaction,
we have those four terms.
And now you see that
sigma plus takes the atom
from the calm to
the excited state.
But sigma plus appears
both with photon absorption
and with photon emission.
So therefore, the
atom can-- this
is what the quantum
mechanical operator
tells us-- go from the
ground to the excited state
either by photon absorption
or by photon emission.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So if we were
to look beyond the dipole
approximation, would
we see transitions
that leave the
[INAUDIBLE] state?
PROFESSOR: Yes or no.
What we need here is a
bilinear interaction,
which has an raising and
lowering operator for the atom.
And here it has a
raising and lowering atom
operator for the photon number.
And it has the co-rotating
term where you raise here
and you lower there.
You lower here and
you raise there.
But it has also terms where you
raise the atomic excitation,
and you raise the
photon number by one,
which of course violates energy.
But the message I want
to give you is this
is possible for short times.
And this is exactly what the
quantum mechanical equations
tell us.
So the short answer
to your question
is, as long as we
describe the system
by the dipole interaction,
or what we have even beyond--
I'm not using a
perturbation argument.
I'm writing down the operator.
And this operator can
now effect the system
to all possible orders.
So even the non-perturbative
strong coupling limit
will always have products
of atomic raising operators,
lowering operators with photon
raising and lowering operators.
The little bit longer answer
is, some of what I'm telling you
may be gauge dependence.
If you work in the-- if you
use, not the dipole description,
but you use the p
dot a Hamiltonian,
this Hamiltonian
has a e square term.
The e square term
allows the atoms
to exchange two photons
at the same time.
So in other words, in
the a square interaction,
we may have a
vertex point in time
where the atom interact
with the photon field
where two photons are exchanged.
And then the rules
are different.
So in that sense-- but
this is quite often
when we give a quantum
mechanical pictures, which
has terms, which nicely
shows the time evolution.
And you think wow, yeah,
this is what happens.
One photon at a
time, the atom goes
ground, excited,
excited, ground state.
And you have your picture.
And it is fully consistent
with the exact quantum
mechanical result.
You may be able to get
the same result out
of a different picture.
That point will
actually occur again
when we talk, for
instance, when we
talk about density operators.
A density operator is an
average of our quantum states.
But you can get the
same density operator
by averaging quantum states
in different basis sets.
So if you get one picture out
of one specific basis set,
it gives you the
correct intuition,
it's a correct
description, but it is not
the only possible description.
[? Collin ?].
AUDIENCE: Maybe the
thing, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: I think
what you're trying
to get at is that picture
works as long as you can limit
yourself to a two level system.
Because that's
correct on a whole.
Or is it like strong coupling?
But as long as you can
identify the two level system,
or I think the dipole versus
particle approximations
[INAUDIBLE] an atom may have
transition probabilities
to others, like from
an [INAUDIBLE] state.
But--
AUDIENCE: Actually,
I was just wondering
if it was possible to have
it like a transition matrix
element to [INAUDIBLE] coupling
the ground state to the ground
state.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The e square operator
does that, because
in the other gauge,
which is pa, pa.
p is in dipole operator.
p is the momentum operator
for the atoms.
And the p operator will
switch the atom from ground
to excited state.
a, the vector potential,
involves a and a daggers.
So the p dot a term does
pretty much the same
as the d dot e
term, because it's
a bilinear product
of an operator which
has an effect on the atoms and
has an effect on the photons.
And it means you always switch
the quantum state in your atom
and create or
annihilate the photon.
But the a squared term--
it's just a square,
it doesn't have a
p in front of it--
will allow an atom in without
changing the state to create
two photons, emit two photons.
And then there's
probably a cross term
which means to absorb
and emit a photon.
You will actually, in one of
your next homework assignments,
you will actually look
at the a square term.
And I think it's a very
educational problem.
So you really see
that you have two
very different descriptions,
but the results fully agree.
But this is already
an expert discussion.
Why don't we for now just hang
onto the dipole approximation.
We have d dot e,
and we just learn
what is inside the
dipole approximation,
and what is an exact quantum
mechanical description using
the dipole approximation.
But and then we can come
back to the discussion,
is everything we
describe really real.
And while the answer
is, what is real
in quantum physics
is the final result,
the intermediate
results, you have
to say that this is
only one possibility
to go to the final result.
OK, so we want to-- let me
just put in one more page.
So what we want to do now is
we want to do a calculation.
It's a perturbative
calculation, but we
can take it to all orders.
So therefore it's
exact and general.
We want to do a perturbative
calculation of transition
amplitudes.
And what I am following here
the discussion in atom photon
interaction on those pages.
And the idea is the following.
We have the Hamiltonian
for the atom.
And then we have a
Hamiltonian which
describes the transverse field.
And the interaction of
the transverse field
with the atoms.
What we want to use is we
want to use the interaction
picture, which is often
the nicest picture
to describe the effect of
the interaction between two
systems.
In the interaction picture,
you are transforming
from you Schrodinger
type e function
to wave function psi tilde.
And those wave function
psi tilde include already
the dynamics of the
Hamiltonian H naught.
So that means that all operators
in the normal Schrodinger
picture become now operators
in the interaction picture
by canonical
transformation, which
involves the dynamics due to
the unperturbed Hamiltonian.
And so that's just
a reminder what
the interaction picture is.
And we are now interested what
happens in the interaction
picture to an initial
wave function psi of ti.
This wave function already
includes the time evolution
due to H naught.
So the only change now comes
because we have interactions
with the electromagnetic field.
So this allows us
now to focus only
on the relevant interactions,
the interactions we
want to understand.
And the formalism which is
used in atom photon interaction
focuses on the time
evolution operator,
which I'm sure all
of you have seen.
So the time evolution
of our system,
how the wave function
involves from the initial
to the final time, is described
by the time evolution operator.
I will come back to the
wave function later,
but in order to derive the time
evolution of the wave function,
it's at least convenient
to focus first
on the time evolution operator.
So in other words,
I want to show
you a formal solution for
the time evolution operator.
And once we know the
time evolution operator,
we apply it to
the wave function.
And then we are talking again
about the wave function.
OK, since the derivation
involves many equations
and they are all printed in
the full beauty in atom photon
interaction, I decided to
use pre-written slides here.
Also, most of it is
fairly elementary.
The equations are complicated,
but the concepts behind them
are very, very simple.
It's actually the
beauty of using
a kind of a time
evolution operator.
It's a little bit
mathematically formal,
but it allows us to
express what is really
going on in the solution
in very, very simple terms.
So the goal is to do a
perturbative expansion
for the time evolution operator.
If we have no interaction
potential v, the interaction
picture, nothing happens
in the interaction picture,
and therefore, the
time evolution operator
is a unity matrix.
But if you have a coupling term
v, there is time evolution.
And the time evolution
can be treated
in lowest or in higher
orders in the perturbation.
And we want to use now
perturbation expansion, where
we have correction
terms, which is
the first order, second
order, and nth order
correction for time
evolution operator.
So what we simply
want to do is we
want to do an
iterative solution.
We want to find an iterative
solution for the time evolution
operator.
The next two lines
is just a reminder.
What is the differential
equation for the time evolution
operator?
Well, we are really just talking
about Schrodinger's equation.
Schrodinger's equation
for the wave function
turns into differential
equation for the time evolution
operator.
Schrodinger's equation in
the interaction picture
says that the time
derivative of the wave
function in the
interaction picture
has nothing to do H naught.
H naught has already
been absorbed
in the definition of
the wave function.
So the time evolution in
the interaction picture
only comes from the
interaction term.
And now, if you write the
wave function at time tf
as the time evolved wave
function from the initial time
to the final time, then you
take the derivative here.
You actually take a derivative
of the time evolution operator.
And therefore, in one step,
from Schrodinger's equation,
you find a differential
equation for the time evolution
operator.
In other words, this is
now the operator equation
for the time evolution operator.
And it's nothing else than a
100% rewrite of the Schrodinger
equation.
Interrupt me if
you have questions.
This part should be--
we'll go through that
for solely pedagogical reasons.
And that means you should
really understand it.
So this equation can
now be formally solved
in the following way.
Take this expression for
the time evolution operator
and insert it in this equation,
and you find an identity.
Of course, you haven't
really solved it,
because you have the time
evolution operator expressed
by the time evolution operator.
This looks like a
circular conclusion,
which is just nonsense.
But if you inspect
it more closely,
you observe that the time
evolution operator here
is expressed by the time
evolution operator multiplied
with v. And if you now think
in an iterative solution
that we want to express.
We want to expand the
time evolution operator
in the different orders in the
interaction parameter v. Then
you find actually
that if you are only
interested in the first order
of the interaction operator,
you can use the
[INAUDIBLE] order here,
because you get one
more power of v.
So that's how you
get the first order.
If you want to know the second
order of the time evolution
operator, you can
plug-in the first order
on the right hand side.
So therefore, you get
an iterative solution.
The first order solution is one.
The [INAUDIBLE] order solution
is the unity operator.
The first order solution is by
just putting the unity operator
here.
The second order solution
is by taking the first order
solution, plugging
it in in here.
And then you get two
integrals over the operator
v. So in that sense,
we have formally
solved the time evolution
of the system in all orders.
So this is what
we get out of it.
Yes, the equations
are getting longer.
But the structure
is fairly obvious.
So you saw that the--
let me just flashback.
The first order term
had a temporal integral
over v. The second order term
has two temporal integrals
over v. And there's a time order
in between tau 1 and tau 2.
And the nth order term now
involves n temporal integrals
where the times are
ordered in such a way.
Now we want to go back to
the Schrodinger equation.
So we want to use this already
fairly complicated expression
for the time evolution
operator and apply it
to the initial wave function.
And we want to calculate
matrix elements
between the initial wave
function and some other phi
f, some other wave
function in a given basis.
So we are also going back.
I don't want to go
through too many steps.
Here, we're also going back
to the original Schrodinger
picture.
So I've taken all
the tildes off.
But you know the step
form the Schrodinger
picture to the
interaction picture
was only taking out the
Hamiltonian H naught.
And the Hamiltonian H naught
for eigenstates phi i and phi f,
is simply a time evolution, e
to the e ei with a certain time.
So all what this transformation
to the interaction picture
gave us, it eliminated, at
least for a short while,
all of those phase
factors, which are simply
the evolution of
the eigenfunction
in the Schrodinger picture.
So let me look at a typical
term which we have right now.
And you can't expect
something simpler
than this, because this
is the general solution.
It's an exact solution
to all orders.
It's a summation over
terms to all orders.
And eventually the summation of
an infinite number of diagrams
is an exact solution.
So what we've got here is we
have an integral over n times.
And the n times
are time ordered.
This is the formal solution for
the time evolution operator.
And that means that we
integrate overall times,
but what it is under
the integral sign
is a product of the
operator v at times
tau 1, tau 2, tau 3, tau 4.
Since we got back to the
Schrodinger picture, what
happens is between
times tau 1, and tau 2,
the particle simply evolves
with the phase factor
given by the
Hamiltonian H naught.
So the picture is the following.
The time evolution operator
in the interaction picture
is a product over the operator
v tilde at different times.
If you simply plug it back
into the above equation--
and you have to look at
it for a little while
to see that everything
works out correctly.
But what that means is then that
if you go to the Schrodinger
picture and write down the
operator in the Schrodinger
in the basis of
unperturbed eigenfunction,
that you have products of
the operator v at times
t1, tau 2, tau 3,
they're time ordered.
And because we have left
the interaction picture,
you also get the propagation
with the phase factors
given by the eigenenergies of
the unperturbed Hamiltonian H
naught.
So therefore, you get
just an infinite number
of terms which have all
the following structure,
that the particle propagates
in its eigenstate.
It reaches a vertex where
the interaction switches
the particle from one
state to the next.
Then in the next state, which
may now be the excited state,
we have propagation
in the excited state.
Then the excited state is,
again, exchanging a photon,
has an interaction term,
and is switched to-- well,
for the two level system, it has
to go back to the ground state.
In a more general situation, it
goes to another quantum state.
So therefore, what we
have exactly derived
is that the propagation,
or the time evolution,
of the wave function
is nothing else then
many, many of those factors.
And each of those factors
can be represented
by a diagram like this.
So let me just write down
what this diagram here
means mathematically.
It means that initially, we
have a photon of energy epsilon,
of polarization epsilon, wave
factor k, and a certain energy.
And we have
particles in state a.
That means that we get from the
initial time to the time tau 1.
And tau 1 is the time
of the first vertex
of the first photon exchange,
that the wave function evolves.
And it evolves with an energy
of the unperturbed Hamiltonian,
which is the atomic energy.
And we have one
photon h bar omega.
At the time tau 1--
and this is when
the diagram on
the left hand side
has a vertex-- we are now
bringing in the interaction
operator, which
acts on the atom.
It takes the atom from
state A to state B.
And it changes the
state of the photon.
In this case, a photon
with a certain wave factor
and polarization
simply disappears.
So this is now the time tau 1.
The next Vertex is
reached at time tau 2.
And between the time
tau 2 and tau 1,
the system evolves according
to the Hamiltonian H naught.
And the energy is now,
because we have no photon,
is simply the energy
of the atom in state B.
Then we reach the next vertex.
We start with a state
B and no photon.
The interaction
switches, as now I
assumed we have more
than two levels.
Two are state C. And we
have now a photon, which
may be different, k
prime epsilon prime.
Since we are now, for this
given example, I've selected n
equals 2, something
which is second order
in the perturbation.
But that means now that
between the time tau
2 and the final tie-in for
the time propagation, that's
now everything is done.
Things propagate.
And the unperturbed
Hamiltonian H naught
gives us now a
phase factor, which
reflects the energy
of the atomic state,
and the energy of
the photon in mode k
prime epsilon prime with
energy omega h per omega prime.
So in other words, I hope you
see that at the end of this--
I mean, this is why people
have Feynman diagrams.
It's a complicated, involved
mathematical formulation
with multiple integrations.
But at the end of the
day, what we have derived
is that the most
general solutions
to all orders in the probation
is nothing else than a sum
and integral over
diagrams like this.
So when I depict it here, the
second order diagram, of course
this has an exact
mathematical meaning.
And what we have to
do is when we solve
a quantum mechanical
equation, we
have to now allow those
interactions, which
happen at time tau 1 and tau 2,
to happen at arbitrary times.
So therefore, we have
to sum over amplitudes
by integrating over
times tau 1 and tau 2.
So on Friday-- I
have to stop now.
I think there's a
seminar right now.
On Friday, I will show you
that with this description,
we have actually captured
everything I explained to you
earlier-- those virtual
states, the emission
of virtual or real photons.
So everything that
which was maybe
qualitative at the
beginning of this section
has now a precise,
mathematical meaning.
But that's what we do on Friday.